>> Larry: ALL RIGHT, OKAY.
THE FIRST THING I WANT TO SHOW
YOU GUYS TONIGHT IS SOMETHING
VERY INTENSE, OKAY.
I'M WARNING YOU, VIEWER
DISCRETION ADVISED.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> Larry: THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT WAS TWO PANDAS DOING IT,
OKAY.
THIS IS A REAL NEWS STORY, GUYS.
THIS IS A REAL NEWS --
PANDAS AT A CHINESE ZOO SET A
NEW SEX RECORD BY GOING AT IT
FOR 18 MINUTES AND THREE
SECONDS.
WOW.
RIGHT, RIGHT?
NO, HEY.
17 MINUTES LONGER THAN SOME LATE
NIGHT HOSTS LAST.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
JUST SAYING, SOME, JUST SAYING.
THANKS FOR THE SUPPORT.
OH, A LOT OF SUPPORT.
WHAT MOST PEOPLE MIGHT NOT BE
AWARE OF IS HOW RARE PANDA SEX
ACTUALLY IS.
THE FEMALE IS ONLY FERTILE FOR
LIKE A 36-HOUR WINDOW ONCE A
YEAR. OKAY?
AND MALES HAVE SUCH A LOW SEX
DRIVE THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAVE TO
GIVE THEM VIAGRA AND SHOW THEM
PANDA PORN.
( LAUGHTER )
I MEAN, YOUR HEART BREAKS FOR
ALL THOSE POOR PANDAS WHO
HAD DREAMS OF BEING LEGITIMATE
ACTORS BUT WERE REDUCED TO
PANDA PORN, RIGHT?